nous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques kiosque votre magazine culturel
sur saint quentin en yvelines et ses
environs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 17 février laurence earl en
plateau avec nous aujourd'hui
ce comédien originaire de l'encours
invite tous les vendredis et samedis
soirs au théâtre du guichet montparnasse
de paris son public à parler d'amour sur
scène avec sa création iloveyou le soin
nous y reviendrons dans quelques
instants
mémoires de trappes a retrouvé au cours
de ses recherches pour retracer
l'histoire de la ville de trappes
l'existence d'un saut celui de guillaume
de trappes
une exposition présentée jusqu'au 9 mars
illustre les recherches en cours de
mémoire de trappes
depuis le mois de janvier le dessinateur
du célèbre marsupilami rend visite aux
élèves de l'agglomération de versailles
grand parc
une visite dans le cadre d'un vaste
projet interdisciplinaire rencontre avec
luc colin connu sous le nom d'artiste
deux baptêmes et nous commencerons cette
émission je vous le disais avec du
théâtre avec moi pour en parler
laurence heures le bonsoir bonsoir alors
laurence heures le vous êtes originaire
d'el en cours et vous produisez
actuellement sur la scène du théâtre du
guichet montparnasse tous les vendredis
et samedis soirs à 19h on vous regarde
tout de suite je vous parle bien
déprimant on dirait presque presque le
début d'une petite annonce à l'ancienne
ça va chercher recherche alsace d'or
samedi devant cherche tangre partenaires
bonne composition de caractère et qui
serait me fait plaisir femme
d'expérience et d'avenir cherche l'homme
idéal s'il existe pas sur une chance sur
un million peut être mais ce soir j
croire vieille fille
sans fortune ni beauté ni talent cherche
mari cherche personne sachant faire la
soupe agréable du tout alors laurent
semble vous êtes un acteur local connu
du territoire parce que vous avez évolué
depuis des années sur les scènes du
prisme à l encours de maurepas et dans
les médiathèques du réseau de saint
quentin en yvelines
vous avez de nombreuses fois d'ailleurs
collaboré avec jacques fournier et les
itinéraires poétique anciennement maison
de la poésie est justement vous avez
travaillé ensemble sur le spectacle que
vous avez créé il ya deux ans à ilo
veyou leçon un spectacle d'une heure
articulé autour d'un travail d'écriture
important est ce qu'on peut parler d'un
spectacle et littéraire moi j oui et
puis pas du tout en même temps
pas du tout parce que je pense qu'il ya
c'est plus joueur que ce que le mot
littéraire peut induire comme ça et là
parce que vous utilisez peut-être
beaucoup de textes oui j'ai d'abord je
lis j'ai écris donc c'est très écrit
donc en ce sens et littéraire mais c'est
vrai que j'aime bien moi quand la
littérature s mais dans une
dans une petite mouvance une petite
mobilité comme ça et que elle perd sa
stabilité
c'est j'aime bien quand elle devient
plus c'est pour ça qu'il ya de
l'interaction aussi avec le public c'est
vrai que ça me permet aussi de faire que
les mots résonnent d'une manière
différente à chaque fois parce que j'ai
aussi l'écho du public qui vient qui
interfèrent directement dessus
donc en ce sens moi je crois que ça
parle d'amour et que ça parle de désir
est que et que d'une certaine manière
c'est c'est le véritable objet est en
fait il ya un support de littérature
avec celle entre un support qui
nécessite quand même un travail d'auteur
conséquent car vous avez écrit plus de
la moitié des textes que vous lisez
largement plus largement largement plus
en fait j'ai quasiment tous écrits mais
simplement comme il ya une forme de
manière de cité qui me permets moi
ensuite de me faufiler derrière avec mon
écriture et du coup c'est très s'est
très
on s'est un peu vanitou peut-être et
c'est moi qui écris et même la manière
dont dans les gens sont cités en fait
c'est ses cours et c'est toujours pour
le mettre dans un film qui qui est mon
fils moi je suis là pour trahir les gens
et donc jeu et même me trahir moi même
de temps en temps mais j'aime bien cette
idée qu'il ya une subjectivité dans tout
ça donc
donc les mots avant j'essaie de
m'appliquer de dire faut surtout pas
trahir l'auteur puis j'ai compris que
c'était une connerie phénoménal il faut
traduire les auteurs ils sont là pour ça
les auteurs alors c'est d'ailleurs
justement un spectacle qui est né d'une
commande du salon du livre de pau qui
vous avait demandé de travailler sur des
séquences de 20 minutes sur les rapports
hommes-femmes donc l'amour en général
est un thème qui s'appuie sur une
littérature très abondante
est-ce que c'était important pour vous
de travailler en tout cas sur un thème
justement qui reposait sur un socle
d'écriture large
j'avais dans mes classeurs et dans mes
dossiers et fichiers word
j'avais un certain nombre de poésie qui
qui étaient en attente
et c'est vrai que quand on m'a parlé de
ce projet évidemment j'ai commencé par
dire non je ne peux pas là tout de suite
c'est trop court et tout et puis quand
j'ai raccroché je me suis dit mais je
suis je suis idiot gère que j'ai je
savais tout de suite que j'avais tous
ces textes là qui qui qui existaient qui
demandait qu'à être remis comme ça dans
le temps dans aidant et en bouche et en
aurait donc c'est parti là dessus en
effet parce que j'avais déjà des données
pour moi j'avais j'avais du ronsard
j'avais déjà fait du jld avait du
rimbaud j'avais du verlaine j'avais dû
cendrars j'avais des gens comme ça qui
ensuite sont ont disparu d'ailleurs ils
sont pas dans le spectacle mais mois
pour réfléchir ça m'a permis vraiment de
partir là dessus et c'est vrai que
j'aime bien mais mais mais simplement
faut comprendre que pour moi la poésie
donc vous parliez du prisme et à l'heure
en fait c'est le théâtre de l'unité
c'est jacqueline chine qui m'a mis le
pied à l'étrier de la poésie vraiment
géré en dehors des sentiers battus
puisque ont déclamé de la poésie en haut
des rochers dans en lozère et c'est là
que moi j'ai appris à aimer la poésie
parce que j'ai compris que la poésie
pouvait devenir immensément grande et
immensément petit et c'est dans ce dans
cette infinie petit que moi je me dirige
puisque j'ai pas forcément les moyens
d'être dans des lieux
très très important donc je vais plutôt
aller chercher le creux de votre oreille
plutôt que d'aller très très loin très
très haut
parce que j'ai pas les simplement les
moyens mais mais mais c'est ça pour moi
la poésie c'est ça c'est ses dimensions
là qui m'intéresse c'est pas c'est pour
ça que c'est en ce sens la littérature
si on la considère comme un un moment de
papier moi je me considère pas sur le
moment de papier on va dire que c'est en
tout cas un support qui vous permet
d'apprendre en une heure à votre public
a déclaré son amour en une leçon et vous
avez souhaité ce spectacle en toute
connivence justement avec ce public
alors c'est très interactif vous le
faites participer tout du long il ya des
blind test des annonces vous le prenez
vraiment à partir vous lui faites
déclamer texte et déclaration d'amour
alors j'étais à votre spectacle donc
j'en atteste particulièrement vendredi
dernier et vous m'avez moi-même fait
participer on regarde avec moi entre ces
deux lectures je dirais un texte à votre
oreille le comme un contrechamp qui
revient sans cesse quelque chose comme
je t'embrasse lot de ta bouche je la
goutte de laval jeu-là mélange le flot
de ta bouche le reflux de talent à
quelque chose de très simple voiliers
harmony avant la pluie attendant fini
avant le bruit de l'eau corps sur les
brindilles le flot de ta bouche le
reflux de ta langue je me demande
moi je me perds ta langue et ma bouée
m'ont amené jeu la croche je l'en las
alors pourquoi justement avoir souhaité
un spectacle comme ça très interactif
pour ces raisons de vitalité de la
poésie
j'ai enfin j'avais envie j'avais pas
simplement envie de donner
j'ai lu la de tout à l'heure quelque
chose à mon propos qui disait que
justement il y avait tout de la
conférence est en fait c'était pas du
tout une conférence y avait tous les
arguments va couler tous les outils la
conférence et ce n'est pas une
conférence est en effet c'est il ya
quelque chose comme ça qui me plaît bien
c'est l'idée c'est que les les personnes
finalement se retrouve dans une
situation d' écoute très énergique hiva
active terre on peut pas être simplement
à se dire tiens ils sont jolis des têtes
hausse et jaunissent que le monsieur lui
dis ça m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que les personnes au
moment où elles l'entendent
elle ne sache pas exactement où ça va
aller où ça va partir et comme ça ils
ont vraiment une écoute et plus âgées
active c'est vraiment pour captiver
j'espère que non peu attentif sans que
les gens soient interrogés il ya quand
même des heureusement il ya des
spectacles qui fonctionne pas là dessus
simplement j'avais j'avais envie de
modifier ce rapport là c'est vraiment ce
à dire que ce que j'aime bien c'est que
à la fin du spectacle
donc vous vous avez été dépassé en
premier et c'est le moment peut-être où
il ya le plus de pression par rapport au
passage puisque les gens savent pas trop
à la fin du spectacle mais je sens que
les gens ils ont envie de venir enfin je
sais pas si vous l'avez ressenti ça ou
non mais il ya plus du tout peur il ya
20 heures il n'y a pas de peur parce que
j'essaye de faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien j'accueille les gens enfin
j'essaie de mettre vraiment les gens
très à l'aise c'est vrai même c'est
presque plus qu'à un moment
d'interactivité c'est un moment
d'échangé de partage
je sais et c'est il ya quelque chose
comme ça qui me king qui me plaît quoi
sert que c'est c'est que à la fin du
spectacle les gens qui sont contents
parce qu'ils ont vécu quelque chose
vraiment il me semble enfin voila moi en
tout cas c'est mon objectif à moi et
voilà quand je sens que ça fonctionne et
que et que les retours qui que que
j'entende vont dans ce sens ça me fait
vraiment plaisir
laurent serge merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et donc
on pourra vous retrouver jusqu'au 26
mars prochain au théâtre du guichet
montparnasse les vendredis et samedis
soirs à 19h pour votre spectacle
iloveyou le soin et une annonce
artistique maintenant depuis 2008 le
château de versailles organise chaque
année une exposition consacrée à un
artiste français ou étrangers pour
offert un point de vue contemporain à
l'héritage fort du château alors pour
succéder à anish kapoor le château de
versailles invite de juin à novembre
olaf eu rélégation l'artiste is la dose
danois jouit d'une reconnaissance
internationale pour son travail sur la
perception le mouvement l'expérience
physique et le sentiment de soi parmi
ces installations les plus célèbres the
weather project en 2003 new york city
waterfalls en 2008
inside the reason en 2014 pour la
fondation louis vuitton et ice watch
derrière réalisation en 2015 à
l'occasion de la coop 21 et une autre
exposition maintenant celle de mémoire
de trappes qui a retrouvé au cours de
ses recherches pour retracer l'histoire
de la ville l'existence d'un saut celui
de guillaume de trappes l'original de ce
saut est aujourd'hui conservée aux
archives nationales
l'exposition quant à elle présentée
jusqu'au 9 mars prochain il utile
lustres par dont les recherches des
mémoires de trappes l'existence d'un
sceau officiel celui de guillaume de
trappes ancien chevalier du xiiie siècle
chanoine de la cathédrale d'orléans a
été retrouvé à l'occasion des recherches
menées par mémoire de trappes ce service
public dédié à l'histoire d'un
territoire en perpétuelle mutation
illustre ses recherches par l'exposition
voyage à travers les sauts du moyen-âge
du 12e au 15e siècle présentée jusqu'au
9 mars
cet exposé entreprend la fabrication
l'utilisation les âges des sceaux avec
des visuels et
des explications très claires et simples
les ça explique aussi également les
grandes familles de la région la ville
de trappes était à l'époque on l'a
trouvé ce nom de trappes xtr aps et
était en fête
reconnu comme gîte royal donc une place
forte qui était entretenue pour que les
monarques viennent puisque lors de leur
voyage dans la région puissent s'arrêter
et trouver le confort et le gîte
cette exposition présente une collection
de moulage des sauts des seigneurs et
chevaliers des yvelines utilisés
autrefois comme signature pour certifier
un acte le saut qui a connu son âge d'or
au 13ème et 14ème siècle renseigne sur
la vie diplomatique et quotidienne du
moyen-âge le sort fait c'est l'empreinte
sur une surface malléable donc à
l'époque c'était la sienne à partir des
matrices qui peut être fabriqué soient
en métal soit en hausse son niveau on va
la retrouver sous plusieurs formes
durant toutes ces années et qui
servirent aux fêtes a signé et on a posé
donc sa signature sur un document de
plus ou moins grande importance pour
mieux comprendre la fabrication des
sauts des ateliers de moulage sont
proposées dans le cadre de l'atelier
ville et des livres et jeux sont
disponibles pour les enfants et jiwa
vient de nous rejoindre en plateau
bonsoir jouets vous êtes street artist
vous faites partie des guest à être
invité par le collectif 1903 under pour
exposer à l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois jusqu'au 26 février
prochain une série de toiles intitulées
sur le graphe giroix un mois peut-être
sur ce collectif
bah c'est une bande de potes avant tout
donc ça fait 15 à 20 ans comprend un
ensemble
donc voila et rallier par l'amour de
l'art urbain du street art comme on dit
c'est un collectif de street art qu'est
ce qui vous plaît particulièrement
justement dans larbins bas à nouveau les
couleurs gratuite oui voilà c'est ça
c'est accessible c'est dans la rue donc
on est tous amenés à passer par la rue
donc c'était ça le but premier prêt on
s'exprime
chacun sa manière les pochoirs le
graffiti alors je vais vous parler
justement de la rue vous avez d'ailleurs
investi les murs de la rue avant la
toile oui c'est un passage obligé pour
tous les goûts
non chacun chacun chacun son parcours
ils ne sortent d'écoles d'art font
directement des tableaux ou de la bande
dessinée on n'a pas ça par la rue
majeure entre le support qu'offre la rue
et le rapport à la toile qu'elle est il
m'a la toile on va plus loin de chez
nous ça va plus on va être plus
concentré alors que la rue asselah rue
en bas à gauche à droite ça se fait plus
au feeling alors qu'une toile un travail
sur toile va être plus réfléchi plus
aboutie en général c'est le pendant
quelque part de l'évolution d'un street
artist la toile vous pourquoi par
exemple est-ce que vous êtes passés sur
toile bas parce que c'est un peu s'il à
la mode ou la continuité on veut
continuer à faire évoluer notre peinture
donc pour entrer un peu de monde de là
dans le monde de l'art c'est la toile
c'est un peu le support entre guillemets
emblématique emblématiques ou
principalement sur les toiles après
enfin sur le plan d'eau d'objets des
supports à plein d'autres choses
et alors justement est-ce qu'on utilise
les mêmes techniques sur dans la rue sur
les muets sur la toile oui oui c'est ça
à peu près les mêmes techniques de base
désolé mais ma l'hérault salle des
bombes aérosols des marqueurs des bombes
des encres utilisées tout tout tout les
mêmes matériaux nous ont fait ce travail
la même façon aussi bien sur la mer que
sur les toiles passe à peu près de la
même façon donc c'est le support qu'ils
changent encore gerald les toiles sont
un peu plus petits klémurs donc obligé
de ce cadre et sa récente histoire mais
bon alors c'est une passion que vous
avez à coeur de transmettre aux plus
jeunes
peut-être au moins jeunes va lui
expliquer par les différents ateliers
que vous organisez aussi bien en centre
de loisirs que dans les dents les
maisons cartier oui voilà ça côté on a
une association bio style biostar
l'association donc on a fait ce bouc et
oui on organise chez les mjc les
collèges et les maisons de quartier ont
fait des décos de chambre
plein de choses et cours de graffitis
sur tous les supports textiles
hélas comme je disais à transmettre
c'est vraiment le fait de pouvoir
s'épanouir pleinement et sans code
définit au travers de la vie voilà c'est
ça mon canton vont se partager
s'exprimer au travers de la rue après
ils vont préférer la musique douce et la
peinture d'autres vous préférez la pêche
ou je sais pas quoi d'autre mais voilà
nous c'est l'art la peinture le plein
air rencontrer des gens partagent et
voilà partage de la liberté à travers le
tarp mais vous alors dit moi d'avoir été
toujours avec nous et je rappelle que
l'exposition sur le graphe du collectif
1903 under est à retrouver à l'espace
philippe noiret jusqu'au 26 février
prochain et depuis le mois de janvier le
dessinateur du célèbre marsupilami rend
visite aux élèves de l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc dans le cadre d'un
vaste projet interdisciplinaire luc
colin connu sous le nom d'artiste de
baptême bien préparer l'agenda qui sera
ensuite distribué aux élèves des écoles
alentours où ils friedrich y est camille
lambert se sont rendus à l'école
élémentaire du pré de saint jean à buc
le marsupilami cet animal imaginaire né
en 1952 sous les coups de crayon du
dessinateur andré franquin reste
toujours autant populaires les plus
jeunes générations continuent à aduler
cette petite bête jaune aux taches
noires d'à peine un mètre ces aventures
aujourd'hui racontés par le dessinateur
baptême s'arrache dans les cours de
récréation à celle avec la famille merci
pile à lui le bouchon qui est en train
de coûter un arbre et le marsupilami et
depuis le mois de janvier ils sont 150
élèves de six classes issues de la
communauté d'agglomération de versailles
grand parc à travailler avec baptême
attentifs aux conseils du maître venu
spécialement depuis la belgique alors
rencontrent deux fois par semaine ils
préparent le prochain agenda scolaire
qui sera distribué dans les écoles du
secteur
ce à quoi je m'attendais pas c'est que
j'allais devoir un peu débattre du fond
et de trouver des idées ensemble sinon
on lit initialement mon but était de
cadres et de canaliser les idées des
enfants pour les aider à illustrer pour
que les images soient claires nettes
impactante commandé aujourd'hui est très
efficace
le projet est mené avec l'éducation
nationale n'est pas uniquement culturel
la réalisation de cet agenda permet
également d'aborder la question de la
protection de l'environnement cause du
réchauffement climatique énergies
renouvelables ou encore éco gestes des
questionnaires notamment viendront
enrichir l'agenda questionnaire préparé
avec les enseignants ces riches parce
que y'a plein de champs disciplinaires
qui ce qui se mélangent le dessin qui
doit porter un message à la fois le
français avec toute la production
d'écrits et puis le côté scientifique
donc c'est vraiment très riche et ils
sont bien impliqués onglet franquette
est lui-même très sensible à l'écologie
bon j'ai toujours été j'ai toujours été
proche de nature je vous ai du scoutisme
et le marsupilami qui vit en pleine
nature et qui va défendre son
environnement
effectivement depuis jeudi dès la
troisième album même peut-être le
deuxième est essentiellement le
troisième album mars au noir qui gagnent
nous avons traité d'écologie 8500
l'agenda seront éditées pour septembre
quant à baptême
aussitôt ce travail terminé il reviendra
dans les yvelines les 8 et 9 octobre à
buc en tant que parrain du festival de
bande dessinée cette fois ci il est
question d'un autre dessinateur à
présent pour l'exposition présentée
actuellement au théâtre de l'espace
coluche de plaisir il s'agit de gilbert
denis s'il a abandonné son métier
d'illustrateur pour la peinture il n'a
pourtant rien perdu de ses fondamentaux
le trait est nette le dessin ferme la
couleur fluide tout en laissant la place
à l'imaginaire ses oeuvres sont des
invitations au voyage
exposition présentée jusqu'au 18 avril
prochain les détails avec vincent besson
directeur du théâtre espace connu il
nous attire beaucoup par ses lignes ces
lignes claires et surtout par cette
admiration qu'il vous non seulement un
gros gars comme il le dit dans son
propre texte
mais la lumière à sion qu'il voue à
brasilia en fait qu'il est très porté
sur l'architecturé il a fait l'école des
beaux-arts et l'école des arts
graphiques
il est très porté sur l'architecturé et
sur la ville de brasilia
vous avez un exemple derrière moi pour
cette netteté des lignes c'est ça qui
nous plaît chez lui et place au cinéma
maintenant comme chaque semaine vos
réactions sur les nouveautés à la fiche
de ce mercredi au micro de camille
lambert
parce que c'est assez comme ces comiques
mais pas trop et ça traite d'un sujet
sérieux
j'étais un peu déçu quoi mais c'est
infiniment c'est une parodie c'est pour
se moquer un peu du cinéma quoi mais va
du cinéma de hollywood
tous les travers tous les vices du
métier mais on s'ennuie un peu quoi
aider moment c'est un peu drôle quand
même
mais on s'ennuie quoi j'ai pas mal y ait
certaines choses sur certains passages
qui sont bien mais bon je sais pas leur
meilleur c'est un bon film très
réjouissante reggae les acteurs sur le
superbe via l'animation qui est superbe
j'avais tout sont ni croire par les bons
des drôles on soir quand vous la voyez
bien et aujourd'hui pour le coup de
coeur du professionnel et c'est cyril à
haddad du cinéma philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois cette semaine notre
coup de coeur et le film 45 ans avec
charlotte rampling kate et john mercer
sont sur le point d'organiser une grande
fête pour leur 45ème anniversaire de
mariage
pendant ces préparatifs joy reçoit
nouvelle le corps de katia son premier
grand amour disparu 50 ans auparavant
dans les glaces des alpes vient d'être
retrouvé cette nouvelle valeur
bouleversé le couple est modifié
doucement le regard que kate porte sur
son mari 45 ans est un film sensible et
cruelle sur le temps qu'il passe et sur
la crise d'un couple
cette chronique dramatique tournée comme
un thriller est superbement porté par
ses deux acteurs principaux
le résultat est remarquable de justesse
nommé pour l'oscar de la meilleure
actrice charlotte rampling
il trouve l'un de ses plus beaux rôles
qui lui donne l'occasion de déployer une
palette de nuances jusqu'à un final
proprement ce sublime 45 ans est proposé
en version originale et est à découvrir
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
et avant de nous quitter je vous propose
un bel agenda culturel pour le week end
jeudi 18 février 20h 30 rendez vous au
théâtre gérard philipe de saint cyr
l'école accélère reprend sur scène en
toute simplicité ses plus grands tubes
extraits de son album ce sont onze
sorties en 2015 on y retrouve sensualité
je t'attends tube de 1994 ou encore
manhattan kaboul tube de 2002 extraits g
john des gestes
je reste
beauchamp
thann
bon
vendredi 19 février 20h30 direction le
scarabée à la verrière dans son nouveau
spectacle
hk reprend 15 chanson française écrite
par les plus grands auteurs
il y ajoute une forme de pince et de
musique de son enfance pour un concert
en forme de voyage entre la france et
l'algérie
on y retrouve le déserteur de boris vian
des chansons de ferrat lavilliers
brassens et brel mais bien sans la
quitter
pas plus mais deux jours la quitterai
bozouls
à plus mais on peut en raconter on ferme
ben amer
quand
sans feu le gars enfants je donne
je
tout le
vendredi 19 février 20h30 toujours
partons pour la merise de trappes pour
retrouver yom clarinettiste virtuose qui
nous livre une traversée épique nautique
d'un ailleurs mystique à la croisée des
musiques orientales et moyen-orientales
avec son spectacle le silence de l'exode
et enfin samedi 20 février 15 heures
venez assister au spectacle rose de la
compagnie du mouton carrés à l'espace
albert camus de maurepas rose est une
petite fille intelligente avec un énorme
défaut de langage mais avec un
formidable appelons grosse remet en
question les règles et les conventions
très vite elle gagne le respect de ses
camarades et réussi à faire de sa
différence une force et c'est la fin du
kiosque pour cette semaine
émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet
merci de nous avoir suivi on se quitte
sur un extrait du spectacle de rose
excellente soirée à tous tu sais rose je
pense que tu es beaucoup plus
intelligente que tu ne le laisse
paraître
non parce que j'ai l'air d'une partie
non non non pas du tout enfin je voulais
dire enfin non ce n'est pas ce que je
voulais dire
moi je pense que le mieux pour l'exposer
ce serait que je commence et que je
finisse vu que c'est moi qui parle le
mieux